[Music]
every day in this country the government
under joe biden or whoever is running
the joint infringes more and more upon
our freedoms pushing americans closer
and closer to the edge the latest the
attorney general of the united states
instructing the department of justice
and the fbi to address threats against
school boards and teachers over covet 19
restrictions masks and critical race
theory saying those threats should be
discouraged and prosecuted the memo
reads that quote constitutional
protections don't extend to efforts to
intimidate individuals based on their
views
wait what
a primer the constitution protects
actions and speech where individuals
seek a redress of their grievances
now however the ag seeks to remove that
constitutional right if you're a parent
concerned about how your children are
being taught the doa actually
threatening parents concerned about
their children
but it's okay to follow a u.s senator
into a bathroom and threaten to take her
out of office it's okay for black lives
matter rioters to intimidate and
literally burn down our neighborhoods
and businesses
but mama
don't even think about objecting to the
ideological racial hatred being hoisted
upon your own children
this is viewpoint discrimination which
is particularly disfavored by the courts
because it restricts speech on a given
subject matter
with limited exceptions the government
cannot pick and choose what speech is
acceptable and what will be suppressed
or viewed as threatening they do not
have that right
the singling out of a particular opinion
for treatment different than other
viewpoints is viewpoint discrimination
the constitution and the united states
supreme court agree that even hate
speech is protected although i'm not
suggesting that that's what's happening
here
the left however is all in
conservatives manufactured outrage over
masks and history lessons took our
school boards hostage like a bunch of
screaming maniacs how one republican
senator is pretending school board
harassment and intimidation aren't off
the charts
some behavior is so bad it's being
compared to domestic terrorism
and by the way how exactly is the fbi
being advised to address these so-called
intimidation efforts nowhere does this
crony of the attorney general merrick
garland who you may recall barack obama
wanted to put on the supreme court
described as a moderate define
intimidation
is parents
waiting sometimes for hours to speak at
a local school board meeting to express
concerns about critical race theory
or the masking of their students
particularly young children
is that in and of itself is that
harassment and intimidation spirited
debate is welcome is a hallmark of this
country all due respect it didn't make
it quite clear it doesn't define those
terms nor does it define harassment or
intimidation
is it reasonable for a school teacher to
feel intimidated if a parent goes to a
school board meeting and says teachers
should not be teaching crt
is that enough for the fbi to make a
visit to your home
how is it that the school board members
are automatically the victims in all of
this
school board members are shutting down
microphones where parents seek a redress
of their grievances school boards are
ordering police to take out parents
shutting down debate when it's the
parents who are paying their salaries
when it's the parents who have a vested
interest in their own children
and if a parent complains about school
board members not reopening the schools
the board members say they'll f them up
i'm not hearing this attorney general
saying any threats will not be tolerated
or we'll send the fbi to school board
homes or teachers homes
no
because he's nothing more than a
political hack
following on the biden marxist agenda
which is reportedly a money maker for
his daughter and son-in-law whose own
company is funded by facebook founder
mark zuckerberg which company allegedly
employs critical race theory in its work
and merrick garland before you sick your
agents against parents have you seen
what your teachers and school board
members are saying about parents
if your parent wants to come talk to me
about how i'm not doing a good enough
job in distance learning
just dare them to come at me are we
alone
yeah
if you're gonna call me out i'm gonna
[ __ ] you up
i want their babysitters back
want to reassess who the victims really
are here
no
you've already decided who to demonize
now in the coming days the doj will
announce a series of measures to address
the rise in criminal conduct towards
school personnel
wait
you mean the national school boards
association sends a letter to you to tee
up the need to categorize parents as
domestic terrorists and that's it
the fbi is now in the middle of parents
and local school board meetings
how about millions of american parents
many of whom were unable to work because
the american federations of teachers
decided they weren't going to teach our
children how about millions of american
parents write a letter to you merrick
garland telling you they feel threatened
whenever they appear before a school
board unwilling to allow them to
exercise their freedom of speech
and why the fbi
they don't even have jurisdiction of
issues on the local level and calling a
parent a domestic terrorist doesn't
change a darn thing they have no
jurisdiction
since when does the fbi that esteemed
agency where every agent is special
there are no agents only special agents
since when do they handle threats on a
local level these aren't national
security issues the local police the
sheriff the d.a they do this every day
doesn't the fbi have better things to do
like follow-up leads that could have but
didn't
like in the boston marathon bombing case
the parkland school shooting case the
jeffrey epstein case the larry nassar
girls olympic case all of them
highlighting the ineptitude of the fbi
or maybe
they were just too busy on political
prosecutions
there is simply no one better than the
local police with their ears to the
ground they know all the characters they
know all the proclivities to handle
these cases
but i guess i forgot
you washington types want to defund the
local police don't you
could it be that local police are being
left out here defunded and demoralized
because you want to get rid of them
not because you don't like police but
because you want a federal police force
a federal police force you and your
political friends can control
this action by an attorney general no
less is federal overreach designed to
silence parents accept an ideology
foreign and unacceptable to them and
call them and categorize them as
domestic terrorists but worse it's
designed to terrorize parents
and stop them from voicing their
concerns
folks
it's all part of the marxist agenda
separate children from their parents
family is not the most important unit
the government is
they've already imposed political
correctness on our free speech
infringing on that speech with the
consequence of being canceled
if it's not acceptable speech to them
and the next step is finding or
outlawing our speech just as they do in
europe here's an example cnn's don lemon
what we post on social media what is
posted on social media should be true so
if it's not true it should be taken take
it down
if it's not true take it down
if it's not true don't allow people to
put it up there have them face
consequences
more punishment for diversity of thought
this is all very serious folks it's one
thing to set standards it's all together
something else to threaten parents when
they are simply looking to protect their
children
our children deserve better
it's time to take your kids out of
public schools
no matter what clueless joe says about
caring anyone who's got kids in public
schools has already lost a year to two
years of teachers being paid to sit at
home while you do their work
your kids have already lost to those in
charter schools and private schools and
religious schools they've lost to other
countries that kept teaching
they are doing you no favors and on top
of that they want to terrorize you and
shut you up
it's time your school taxes follow your
child it's not smart to poke mama bear
when she's protecting her cubs
you never know what's going to happen
and that's my open
let me know what you think on my
facebook and twitter hashtag judge
shanine hey sean hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to fox news youtube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else